en el vídeo pasado analizamos esta
gráfica de la función fx y llegamos a
una conclusión interesante de los
máximos y los mínimos y como estaban
relacionados con los puntos críticos
entonces encontramos que se había un
mínimo un mínimo mínimo o sea había un
máximo máximo de f de f en x igual aa
entonces teníamos que a era un punto
crítico a ese punto punto crítico y esto
de punto crítico pre crítico es que su
derivada del acero que o sea que f
primera era cero o bien efe primera no
estaba definida también mismos que al
revés no necesariamente se valía pero lo
que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
encontrar un criterio adicional en
términos de la derivada para ver cuando
un punto es mínimo o máximo ninguna de
las dos entonces vamos a empezar con
este punto que era el máximo global que
se llamaba x0
x 0 y vamos a ver cómo se comporta la
derivada al pasar de antes de x 0 a
después de x 0 sale entonces mira antes
de x0 que le sucede a la derivada pues
la función es creciente la función es
creciente verdad conforme vamos
avanzando hacia la derecha
crecemos entonces eso qué quiere decir
eso quiere decir que la derivada es
positiva en toda esta parte de acá
también puedes dibujar las rectas
tangentes y ver que tienen pendiente
positiva va entonces antes del punto x 0
tenemos que f prima f prima es mayor que
0 entonces la derivada es mayor que 0 y
por tanto la función es creciente o al
revés ahora qué sucede cruzando x0 pues
al cruzar x0 como ésta ya quiere un
máximo entonces ahora la pendiente va a
ser negativa verdad la derivada va a
tener este un valor negativo entonces
aquí tenemos que f prima es menor que
cero o en otras palabras que la función
es decreciente entonces qué sucedió
en este punto crítico que es x0 déjame
escribirlo por acá vamos a ponerle que
sucede en el máximo le voy a poner
cuando a es máximo máximo sale o sea es
el punto crítico aquí es igual a x0
entonces cuando a es máximo que sucedió
sucedió que la pendiente
se dio que f prima cambio de signo
cambia de signo
de signo de que puede ser positiva a ser
negativa entonces cambia de signo más
sino menos al cruzar al cruzar
al cruzar a sí entonces en este punto
crítico cambio de más a menos vamos a
ver si nuestro criterio si tiene sentido
por ejemplo vamos a ver qué sucede con
este máximo global entonces aquí antes
de este punto que se llamaba x2 déjame
ponerle que espera que esté acá era x 1
y que estoy por a caer x 3
pero antes de cruzar x2 tenemos que la
pendiente la pendiente es positiva
verdad vamos para arriba la función es
creciente y por tanto f prima es mayor
que 0 pero al cruzar este punto x2
tenemos un cambio digo es un cambio
abrupto pero es un cambio a que la
pendiente ahora se vuelve negativa
entonces aquí tenemos que f prima es
menor que cero y acá tenemos que f prima
efe prima es mayor que 0 entonces una
vez más cambiamos de tener un signo
positivo a tener un signo negativo en
este punto que era un máximo local hasta
ahorita todo va muy bien ahora también
sería bueno verificar que este criterio
no detecta como máximos puntos que no lo
son por ejemplo este x 3 que no era ni
mínimo ni máximo que le sucede pues a
ver aquí tenemos que la pendiente es
negativa la función es decreciente y de
hecho en todo este caso de acá es
decreciente verdad y justo en x 3 se
hacía 0 entonces
efe prima es menor que 0 aquí acá y que
sucede al cruzar x 3 al cruzar x 3 la
función sigue siendo decreciente y por
tanto la pendiente sigue siendo negativa
muy bien entonces nuestro criterio al
menos no no no no nos dio un falso
positivo verdad no nos dijo que x 3
fuera máximo sin que lo fuera entonces
al parecer el criterio está bueno
ahorita no lo vamos a demostrar nada más
es para darte la idea pero ahora vamos
al punto mínimo
cuando hay un mínimo y creo que puedes
ver a dónde va esto verdad creo que
puedes ver qué va a suceder en este
punto en x1 ahora qué sucede con las
pendientes pues antes de x1 antes de x1
tenemos que la pendiente de las
tangentes es menor que cero o sea que la
derivada es negativa la función es
decreciente si la función es decreciente
y al cruzar x1
ahora tenemos que la función empieza a
crecer y justamente empieza a crecer
porque si nuestros de aquí no sería un
mínimo verdad en el mínimo justo sucede
que bajamos bajamos bajamos bajamos
llegamos al mínimo y luego empieza a
crecer entonces aquí
efe prima es mayor que cero y antes de
eso f prima es menor que cero
escribiéndolo en palabras eso lo que nos
dice es que si tenemos un punto crítico
entonces y bueno y ese punto crítico es
un mínimo entonces f prima cambia cambia
de signo de signo
- asignó más al cruzar cruzar
y bueno ya nada más para verificar que
si aguanta nuestro criterio vamos a ver
qué sucede en el punto x 3 aquí
tendríamos que ver si no cambia de menos
a más pero no verdad ya vimos que está
en negativo y sigue siendo negativo y
por tanto nuestro criterio pues o sea x
3 no es un contraejemplo para nuestro
criterio entonces ya tenemos que si es
máximo cambia de más a menos si es
mínimo cambia de menos a más en este
punto x 3 no pasa ninguna de las dos
cosas y entonces este punto x 3 no es ni
máximo ni mínimo